hot breath something i heard you say
that really stuck with me
is that you started to find your voice
when you started
writing jokes that like you were
attached to
and i'd be interested to hear more about
like
that process because finding your voice
is something all comedians and me
i'm just now 10 years in that i feel
like i'm starting to get
like oh maybe if i do a little more
sarcasm it works better
but like still being attached to
material is something i'm trying to work
towards how were you able to do that
what was that process
uh i i think with
they say like there's no official
timeline but they said what is it eight
to ten years is how long it takes to
find your voice in every comic that's
four years and it's like no i found my
voice right now
and then if you stay in it long enough
and get to ten years you're like
oh i was uh totally wrong i was wrong
about uh my voice for and when i was
four years in
but i think it's the difference that
when you start you're not really
you don't really know how to process
your life and your life's experiences
into comedy yet but you know how to
write a joke
you know you know you can watch you know
you could watch joke writers you could
watch seinfeld you don't learn anything
about seinfeld's life
from watching seinfeld's comedy but
that's that's joke writing that's what
you need
first right you know you need you need
that skill
and then you could take that skill and
apply it to your actual life
and that i think is where you start to
find your voice because you're like oh
this is a situation that actually
happened to me
at the store or in a relationship so
it's truth i'm talking my truth
but i also have this skill set of how to
take that truth
and put it into a format that is a joke
and that's where i think it starts to
fall in like
like you're saying like you like you
lean into sarcasm more like oh maybe
that's
my style and that's how i convey
the things i want to say not just like i
i look back at my early years of comedy
i know like oh this was a setup and a
punchline it did nothing about me
it was just a joke and then
you you you figure out that
it's more rewarding but for me i find it
more rewarding to like oh my
my personal experience is like well
we're laughing at my personal
experiences
not punching down but like i get to talk
about myself i think that's what voices
you like
but then again i love mitch hedberg and
that guy never talked about his life at
all
yeah and that your line on your first
album where it's like you wake
you ever wake up and pretty much it's
like wake up and believe in yourself
like that was almost like a spark for
you that kind of you started to use that
as kind of a jumping off point to start
building material what was it about that
line
that really kind of opened up the next
level of your comedy
i think as i thought my life was in the
in the best most humorous way pretty
stupid
uh you know and there's no uh
there's hardly any originality the boy
the whole the dumb guy
the dumb guy routine that's worked in uh
sitcoms
from the dawn of television you know
the old schlubby boy look at this dumbo
guy
but if i was talking about specific
situations in my life you can't take
that away from me you can't tell me it's
hack if it's
my actual life if me you know
if me walking through the grocery store
drunk holding a
12-pack balance of frozen pizzas on it
just having a good time
even though that's typical dumb guy
that's my that's what i did on a
saturday
night and that was funny to me that i
was still happy in the midst of that
being my lonely saturday night but yeah
it was i was
realizing that also i had i was relating
to a lot more people of like
that was maybe that was death of the
party that was 2009
but so that means those jokes were in
the works in the mid-aughts
which was plenty of people that spent
ridiculous amounts of money to go to
liberal arts colleges thinking that
you're right to pursue your dream and
then all you got was debt
and not a career that was if you were
lucky
maybe distantly related to what you
really wanted to do
so i think that material
struck with a struck a chord with a lot
of people that were like oh yeah i don't
think we're gonna get
the life we wanted to even though we
just spent
you know tens of thousands of dollars on
an education
that was worthless and now we're in debt
which we're seeing more of now
and it's not i don't think it's barely
even funny anymore because now the cost
of education
has skyrocketed compared to the cost
compared to inflation and now it's now
it's a total show right i was
making fun of it before it was just a
little bit of a show no it's a
whole business
but i think it related i think the
laughs i got from that
was like it was maybe it was funny but
also that people
related to it and that's you know when
you watch a comedian you're like
people love jim gaffigan because he
talks about food guess what everybody
has to eat to stay alive you're going to
relate to food
relationships everybody gets lonely they
want to you know
you know regardless of i think you know
gender or sexuality
still there's still some inherent need
to be with somebody so the idea of a
relationship
is still relatable to most people on
earth
so being a you know 30 something
early 30s loser with student loan debt
and a pointless day job related to a lot
of people
and that self-awareness i guess is what
translates it starts with like being
aware of who you are and how you got
there
and then maybe like letting your
material bloom from that is what
seemingly more personal it's almost like
the more universal
and the material becomes
yeah i mean you know you never want to
be
disingenuous i mean like that's that's
you end up pricing yourself out of the
market if you do a good enough job
complaining about how shitty your life
is and being broke and having shitty day
jobs
well then i got rewarded with a career
in comedy well guess what i'm not
broke and i don't have a shitty day job
anymore i'm not going to go and
act like i am because then that just
turns into larry the cable guy and it's
just a caricature
of like uh oh man i'm only making nine
dollars down at the pizza hut tonight no
that's not
the truth of my situation so
i gotta try and make more relatable
material now about